- - C'est l'un des terreaux
leles plus fertiles pour le
PaParti conservateur.
- - Maxime Bernier!
(a(applaudissements)
- - Mais en Alberta, une autre
foformation politique séduit
dede plus en plus d'électeurs
dede droite.
D Des é électeurs comme Craig
MoMostat, qui votaient bleu dans
lele passé, mais qui ne se
reretrouvent plus dans le parti
d'd'Erin O'Toole.
C Craig appuiera Maxime Bernier
cecette fois-ci. Le petit gars
dede la Beauce, qui est devenu
lele porte-voix des non vaccinés
etet des opposants aux mesures
sasanitaires.
MAMAXIME BERNIER, chef,
PaParti populaire dudu Canada
- - Je pense que cette électionà
vava êtrtre un référendum
susur le passeport vaccinal.
PHPHILIPPE J. FOURNIER,
chchroniqueur à L L'Actualité
- - Si un canadien sur 10 est
ananti-vaccin et que Maxime
BeBernier est le seul à p parlen
leleur nom, en soit, ce n'est ps
nénécessairement surprenant
dede voir le PPC monter.
- - Cette analyste de sondages
lele note. Depuis le début de la
cacampagne, les intentions de ve
dudu Parti populaire sont passés
dede 2-3 % à 6-7-7 %.
U Une montée légèrere, mais qui
popourrait faire mal aux
coconservateurs, surtout là o ùs
sese livrent une chaude lutte
avavec les libéraux.
- - Ça pourrait peut-être e faie
babasculer quelques siègeges pls
seserrés, les siègeges urbains
paparticulièrerement. On parle
dede Winnipeg, Calgary, Edmonto,
ouoù les conservateurs devraient
gagagner théoriquement, mais avc
cecette division du vote,
pepeut-êtrtre que ça va être e s
seserré que l'on croit.
- - Le chef Erin O'Toole ne se
momontre nullement préoccupé.
ERERIN O'TOOLE, chef,
PaParti conservateur du Canada
- - Non, parce que je suis le sl
chchefef qui peut remplacer
JuJustin Trudeau.
- - Le chef libéral, qui s'est
fafait lancer un nombre
inincalculable d'insultes et mêe
dudu gravier par des militants
dudu Parti populaire, s'inquièt.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU, chef,
PaPartrti libéral du Canada
- - Malheureusement, on voit que
lele Canada n'est pas à l l'abri
dedes mêmemes mouvements populis
exextrémistes intolérants.
- - Le Parti populaire pourrait
jojouer les trouble-fêtetes pour
leles conservateurs dans quelqus
cicirconscriptions au pays, mais
cece n'est pas mêmeme pas sûr re
lala formation réussisse à faiae
élélirire un seul député aux
CoCommunes. Le siègege le plus
prprenable est celui où se
prprésente Maxime Bernier
enen Beauce, mais c'est aussi
auau Québec où son parti est
lele moins populaire.
I Ici Laurence Martin,
R Radio-Canada, Vancouver